this is the new 1 billion pound Stadium
belonging to the eighth richest football
club in the world
and this is Tottenham Hotspurs Cham and
Daniel Levy paid seven million pounds
this year that the club owned by
billionaire Joe Lewis is also using the
government's furlough scheme effectively
taxpayers money to pay their staff like
caterers cleaners and security meanwhile
their millionaire players along with the
rest of the Premier League continue to
be paid full wages and some people are
not happy about it some of my colleagues
in the NHS who've made the ultimate
sacrifice of going into work and have
caught the disease and have sadly died I
think the last thing the first thing
that Premier League footballers can do
is make a contribution take a pay cut
and play their part top flight football
stands accused of operating in a moral
vacuum but Sky News understand some
Premier League clubs are keen to agree
to a blanket reduction of 25 percent of
players salaries the proposal will be
voted on during a teleconference call
tomorrow that clubs like titleholders
Manchester City such a move would save
tens of millions of pounds and do much
to rescue their public reputation but in
the championship players certain clubs
including Leeds United have already
volunteered significant wage cuts and
high-profile figures a warning against
demonizing footballers in a way the
club's throne plays a little bit under
PR bus if you like it's now up to the
players how they respond let's give them
a chance to respond before this hugely
judgemental pile on that we always get
nowadays and you know what football is
always an easy target obviously but you
know what I hate what about Rick but
we're the big businessman where are the
CEOs of these enormous companies what
are they doing at them at the moment in
a statement the players union the PFA
said we're aware of the public sentiment
that the players should pay non-playing
staff salaries however our current
position is that as businesses if clubs
can afford to pay their players and
staff they should
we still don't know when football will
be allowed to resume and if runaway
leaders Liverpool will eventually lift
the trophy but this is an industry which
remains very much in the public glare
and will be judged accordingly Martha
Kellner
Sky News